foreign
from the headquarters of Ramsey
Solutions broadcasting from the PODS
moving and storage Studios it's the
Ramsay show we help people build wealth
do work that they love and create actual
amazing relationships thank you for
joining us America Jade washout remsey
personality is my co-host today as we
talk about your life and your money it
is a free call a triple eight eight two
five five two two five thank you for
being with us Shawna is on the line in
Indianapolis to start this hour hi
Shawna how are you
I'm good how are you Dave better than I
deserve what's up
my question
how would I balance wanting to be a
ble how much is your crippling student
loan debt
well mine is 192 000. are you a doctor
or a lawyer
Pharmacy yes sir okay good
all right so you can make 100 to 150 a
year
okay
what about your husband are you married
I am how much does one
sorry uh he makes about 33 000 a year
and how much debt does he have is he
bringing to the table
uh like 45
000.
okay so to all you aspiring
pharmaceutical students
you need to listen to this call really
carefully because Shawna what you were
told and what you believed was
oh it's no problem to go two hundred
thousand dollars in debt to become a
pharmacist because I'm going to make a
lot of money
right
now I want to be a stay-at-home mom
yes and that child that made that
decision that was 19 years old
to go two hundred thousand dollars in
debt
you want to go back there and kick that
child's butt now yes so true what's
happening that's making you say I want
to stop what I'm doing right now and
become a stay home mom
are you pregnant do you have a
two-year-old what's the situation
yes we have a two-year-old our only
child so far and we would like to have
several more
what if you okay I'm going to tell you
what I would do if it were me I would
try to stick this out for two more years
and work my butt off and get this debt
cleaned up and then I would feel peace
about staying at home expanding the
family and having a little bit more
freedom there you don't have to try what
do you make
uh historically yeah somewhere in the
range of you know 70 to 100 000 a year
just depending on like part-time work
and stuff like that I thought Dave said
between one and two one hundred and two
hundred thousand I should know between
one and 150 so you're low on the
Spectrum really
um yes yeah Pharmacy work for the
pandemic oh sorry yeah that's okay the
so the good news is you can pick up as
you already know part-time Pharmacy work
like er work and that kind of stuff and
you're probably gonna have to do that uh
if your husband makes forty five
thousand to survive
yeah average household income in America
is 71 000.
yeah so if you want to live on 45 you're
going to be at about you know you're
approaching half of average I think we
call that lower income what is it you
want to raise three kids while you have
a pharmacy degree so you're probably
using that Pharmacy degree for the rest
of your life unless your husband gets
his
um in some way maybe part-time but uh
unless he gets his career really geared
up do you see what I'm saying yes what's
he do now
he is a like a remote sales rep
what's what's the projection for him
what's it looking like over the next two
three years
well so he's actually trained in
chaplaincy but we moved to where we live
now for Ministry purposes so he's been
you know he hasn't been able to find a
chaplain job recently so basically right
now we're sitting at you know 30 30
something thousand forty something
thousand but train is a chaplain he
could make you know starting at 50 and
go up from there we're just still
looking into him being able to find some
kind of role in this area yeah I got you
okay well here's the thing
um
the bad news is you have to pay for the
decisions of the 19 year old you
yes mathematically there's no way to get
out of that I'm sorry I wish it wasn't
the case and I'm not mad at you for that
but you really don't have mathematically
the arithmetic tells us you don't have a
lot of choices you're gonna work really
hard and live on nothing for at least
two or three more years to get this mess
cleaned up agreed yeah
probably many yeah more well no I think
I think you could do it in that period
of time I mean if you throw you know
let's consider this you think you're
going to reduce your household income to
about 90 at some point if you did a 30
or 40 000 part time and he gets up to
60. so that's like five years from today
does that sound right
but yeah and so let's live on 90 and go
make 200 well that's another 100 to
throw at student loans you'll be done in
two two and a half three years
yeah but both of y'all got to get it in
gear because this is the time to do it
when they're little bitty that's right
because they don't even know
they don't even know yeah I kept my
son's two-year-old he was gone for a
week he never noticed his parents were
gone
so now granted granted he was at Mimi's
house which is somewhat like heaven but
um you eat anything you want you do
anything you want but um because that's
the grandmother spoiling technique and
so uh but yeah but aside from that I
mean they really don't I'm not I'm not a
child development expert but they'll
live while you go crazy for a short
period of time so that when they're six
you can be available
yeah and I think I think there's a path
here that gets you there that gives you
hope and it is a light at the end of the
tunnel that's not an oncoming train but
it involves a very intense next 24 to 36
months on both you and your husband's
part in order for you to be able to go
to part-time
yeah
and um I think you can make 30 to 40
part-time some weekend ER stuff or some
even evenings or whatever that won't
destroy your motherhood plan don't you
yeah that definitely seems possible yeah
that's your long-term play to supplement
your husband's uh career goals and you
know because you're going to have to
make it it sounds like on long term on
80 90 100 somewhere in there uh because
we're not going to have your 100 unless
you're working full time so right it'll
be worth it that's what I can tell you
Shawna it's going to be worth it if you
do this now yeah I I I would
go completely bananas for a short period
of time to get your life back
to get it back from that 19 year old
decision so
um so moms and dads when you say oh it's
okay
and school counselors oh it's okay
see the other thing that I've had happen
is much more she has a a an Earnest real
thing but we've had a lot of other calls
that weren't as
sweetest situation right the child they
have a baby the child has uh is a
tremendous special needs situation where
Mom literally or somebody's got to be
there yeah they don't have choice and
yet they're looking at the student loan
debt that was made on the basis on the
auspices
oh it's okay everything's gonna be all
right you make a lot of money
yeah well you don't know what this thing
called life comes up and smacks you in
the head and nobody tells people that
when they're 19 anymore so you all need
to tell these 19 year olds stop it
because they may want to make different
choices later and yet she has a master
in her life called debt the borrower is
slave to the lender man I hope she can
do it she can do it in her situation but
man that hurt her situation is a lesson
for America yes it is to listen to this
is the Ramsay show
[Applause]
y'all there's a lot you can't control
when it comes to health care but there
is something you should check out that
can help Christian Healthcare Ministries
chm is not Insurance it is budget
friendly biblically based Health cost
sharing that means a community of
members helping share the burden of each
other's health care costs they help
people just like you in all 50 states so
C of chm could be right for your family
learn more today at
chministries.org budget
[Music]
thank you
Jade warshaw Ramsey personality is my
co-host today open phones at triple
eight eight two five five two two five
our question of the day comes from
neighborly
your hub for Home Services spring is
here and neighborly can help you with
your home and your yard and keep it all
in top shape with the ground Skies
mosquito Joe Lawn Pride Molly Maid and
more so spend time and more time
enjoying your home not working on it go
to neighborly.com and check out the
service pros in your area this is a
great company it is and today's of the
day comes from Jonathan in the
Netherlands he says we really don't feel
the necessity or the urgency to follow
the beans and rice style of baby step
two I can imagine that it might feel
nice to have no debt and we have no
intention of getting further into debt
however I don't feel it's worth living
on rice and beans for three years to pay
off forty three thousand dollars of
student loans as soon as possible as
we're young we're a young family we're
making sixty five hundred dollars a
month and now we can use our income and
savings to buy a second hand bigger car
make a garden uh make our garden a bit
nicer and later in life we'll have more
to spare to pay off those loans anyway
what are your thoughts on this and would
it be what would be the benefit of still
following the baby steps more rigidly
that's a really good question and you
know what Dave I hear this a lot I think
a lot of people are like why do I have
to be so urgent why do I have to be so
intense and I look at it a couple of
different ways
um number one the series of steps that
we follow
um this is a guy you know Jonathan I
don't mean any harm but you're kind of
just an ish guy right you're doing what
you want to do you're really not on our
plan and that's fine you don't have to
be it's your prerogative but the way the
steps work is you're doing them
consecutively and the first three three
you're doing them with intensity so that
you can get to the final four which is
really that wealth building area so
there's
um some method to this madness but this
kind of goes back to what we've talked
about before
um
there is urgency because how many I mean
I think about my grandmother who would
say you know if you want to make God
laugh tell them your plans and there is
something to be said for that I think a
lot of people just Coast through because
they think hey you know this is my plan
if I just go out like this it's going to
go you know check off the boxes like
that but you really don't know what's
going to come your way you know God
willing everything goes fine and you
know you you'll keep that income and
everything will be perfect and
everybody's healthy and ever but you
don't know that and I think that you've
got to live each day to the fullest you
got to do the best that you can with
each day that you're given and when
you've got debt pay it off you got forty
three thousand dollars of debt and you
make a fine income it doesn't have to
take you three years to pay this off you
could honestly pay it off a lot faster
than that and at the end of the day
Jonathan what she's trying to say is
your plan sucks it sucks it sucks
because it's not gonna work
people have been trying to do the crap
you're talking about
for 50 years
and it doesn't work
you can't sort of kind of get out of
debt and ever get out of debt
it doesn't work it's just actual that
you can't find any proof text in the
marketplace of someone who wanders along
and Lolly gags and sticks with it and
gets out in 10 years but plants his
little garden well give me a break call
the wambulance
you know seriously this is ridiculous
this is just somebody who doesn't want
to sacrifice to him well period that but
you're not going to win okay because
there's no middle ground with this
really now I've been doing this a long
time it's not just that you're not doing
our stuff so please do not follow the
baby steps please do not tell people
you're doing Ramsay no he's not doing it
because I don't want to be insulted by
your abject failure
and I don't want my brand damaged by it
okay just because it's not going to work
here's the reason Jonathan all right the
thing works like this if you don't
really with great intensity focus on a
dramatic change in Behavior where you
have been going in the wrong direction
you will never change the behavior
we're not asking you to live on beans
and rice the rest of your life
and only come out on Triple Coop on
Thursday but what you're doing will not
actually work because it's not
sustainable because it has absolutely no
energy
I just think I'm gonna kind of wander
I'm gonna get a nice house and it's all
going to work out no it's not Jonathan
no it's not because you're gonna get
your freaking head taken off by life and
you're going to look up 15 16 years into
your little marriage and go Dad come we
are stupid people we are still treading
water and ask all these people that are
45 and 50 years old that tried to wander
out and then they found us and in 36
months they got out of debt and they do
their debt free scream they'll tell you
they'll tell you your little plan sucks
because it does it won't work is why it
sucks and when you're lukewarm like that
you say I have no intentions of getting
back into debt yeah you will yeah you
will you definitely will because you're
not committed to the idea the the idea
of where debt Freedom will take you
which is into wealth and into a whole
nother realm of generosity then you can
even grasp right now is not appealing to
you as much as your garden
give me a break
seriously will not work Jonathan will
not work so you can go do what you want
to do but please do not associate my
name with it because I don't want to be
tied to your failure and you go I tried
that Ramsey staff and it doesn't work no
you didn't
no you didn't because we know that
there's a high probability you are never
going to get out of debt unless you
attack it like your dad gum life depends
on it you got to get so fired up and
wired up that your character shifts your
neuro plasticity moves and the way your
brain works where when you see debt you
recoil when you pull up next to a nice
car at a traffic light you now no longer
go oh that's a nice car you go that
fool's got payments yeah well you know
he right now he's stuck in Comfort his
life he feels comfortable he says I
don't think there's any need to get
uncomfortable to change this I'm cushy
the greatest thing to get greatest enemy
of Excellence is not bad things the
greatest enemy of Excellence is the okay
yep just fine I'm okay it's just fine
I'm okay that's so true Dave no you're
not you suck you're not okay your plan
sucks yeah it's it's pitiful and it's
not going to to work dead is like riding
a motorcycle it's not if you crash it's
when you crash because you will crash
remember that
why are you looking against motorcycles
I'm just saying it's not if it's when
George George and horses shooting
motorcycles like you won't get me on a
bike if you crash but when you crash
that's dead they call them
coma mobiles or something oh gosh that's
even worse than what I said Dave
my wife told me I could have a
motorcycle but she wouldn't be there so
there you go that's how that works you
and Sharon you and Sharon we I think we
have a lot in common being Sharon yeah
no doubt about that all right up next is
Andy in Phoenix hey Andy welcome to the
Ramsey Show
thanks for taking my call sure what's up
so I'm in baby step six which I'm like
three months away from being done with
good my job my job
um craze a couple weeks starting a new
rule change they now are insisting that
we all have credit cards to pay for our
expenses how are you paying for them
uh the company was paying for
and so now they want you to carry debt
for them
well wow that's interesting
so what it is is we put in on the credit
cards and then we file paperwork I know
the corporate expense account on the
person's credit card is the biggest con
ever sold to employees in American
history
yeah and these guys because this big old
company can't handle
their own credit card instead they need
to get you to borrow money to travel on
their behalf
right and you know when I first started
baby step two I paid off 28
000 in credit cards how much are you
spending every month
on it
well right now the company's paying for
but it will probably end up be right
around 5 000 a month yeah put seven
thousand in a separate checking account
run a debit card on it because when
you're running a debit card on it and
it's and you're realizing it's your own
money you'll never use it for anything
except reimbursables and reimbursables
will always put the money back in the
account you can travel the next month
reimburse get the money back in the
account travel the next month and you're
not going to get burned that way but
this is a complete corporate scam has
been for decades this is the Ramsey Show
foreign
[Music]
if you're like most people your home is
your most valuable asset and when you
want to make improvements it can feel
like everything costs too much or takes
too long but something as simple as
custom window coverings from blinds.com
can completely change your space and add
value to your home we've recommended
blinds.com for over a decade so you know
you can trust them from blinds drapes
and shutters to motorized Shades they
make it easy and affordable to upgrade
your entire home and their team is ready
to help with everything from design
consultation to measuring and
installation plus there are never any
misleading quotes or hidden fees ever
things backed by their 100 percent
satisfaction guarantee and shipping is
always free see whyblinds.com is the
number one online retailer of custom
window coverings go to blinds.com now
and save 40 off selected products visit
blinds.com today for more info
foreign
[Music]
personality is my co-host today
Stephanie is in Lubbock Texas hi
Stephanie welcome to the Ramsey Show
hi Dave thank you for taking my call
sure what's up
um forgive me I'm nervous
um okay we've never lost
okay so I'm 32 years old I've got I'm a
single mom of a two-year-old I'm living
with my family working as a server
trying to go back to school
I've got twenty two thousand dollars
saved
um partially selling a vehicle I still
have one truck that's IO 17.5 on it I
have student loans of thirty two
thousand dollars
and I'm so I'm just not sure which
direction to go and
um how do you find yourself here
so my husband decided he didn't want to
be with me more after uh my son was born
six months after he was born so I'm
sorry
how long were you married
um three years you're getting childish
together for nine so we I am yeah good
okay
wow
I just feel bad for living with my
family I'm trying to no you don't no no
no no no no no you you are who should be
living with your family right this
second not forever but for a short
period of time this is called a safety
net not a hammock
yeah your your mom and dad are good
people that's what they should do and
you shouldn't you should accept that
right now because you would do that for
your baby
yeah until she got back on her feet now
we got to have a long-term plan that's
not that
but for the short term this is a heat
this is a time of healing and resetting
and
getting getting going again
so um can I ask you some practical
questions
so what are you receiving in child
support
about 700 a month
um so this last term I decided to go
back to school because I didn't know
what to do I was just like I need to be
able to make more money so I was like
um maybe a nurse that would take a
shorter time I would rather not be a
nurse I would rather be have multiple
friends that are occupational therapists
but that would take like five years
since I'm still kind of feel guilty for
doing and I don't make that much more
than nurses but um exactly so I was just
like I feel guilty but in the long run
I'm like okay three more years but it
would give me a better family life but
I'm looking into I mean I'm I've got
FAFSA I've got the grants but after grad
undergrad they don't cover you know it's
like I would have to rely fully on
scholarships or savings so I'm just like
it's kind of up in the air it's like is
that a bad decision
um to do that it's not a bad decision it
feels a little bit like you're doing
this
only for money
I like health
Health Science I love
I love being in the healthcare World
okay all right that's good I didn't
realize that okay because I mean I
you're in a desperate situation
that you've landed in and you have to be
careful I do when I'm in those
situations to not be to not make
decisions based on desperation because
they're never good decisions so you know
the question is the way I always ask
myself is way out there so how old are
you
32. okay so when we're sitting with the
42 year old Stephanie and she's doing
the thing that changed her life and made
her good amount of money for her and her
baby and she feels confident secure in
control and happy to go to work every
day what is 42 year old Stephanie doing
okay then we need to figure out how to
do that
okay and maybe a Nursing degree is a
step towards becoming an OT because you
certainly could use a lot of that
training and even the class even the
transcript to step over into OT correct
yeah because you need some you need some
money in in 12 to 14 months you're not
even going to get that with the nursing
track right
in 12 to 14 months I'm making that up
but I mean oh how long are you going to
live there
that's my big question doesn't need to
be a question that's where your stress
is coming from
yeah stress doesn't come from hard
things stress comes from not knowing
yeah there's a lot of unknowns in this
equation so I'll tell you what I tell
folks to do and what I do is whenever
there's a lot of ideas circulating in my
head I literally go in with a pin a
pattern and a pin and I just start
writing down the plan I write down a
column of all my options I write down
the pros and cons and I sort it out on
paper and a lot of times it's going
through you know one whole sheet tearing
that one off and then you know taking
what makes sense from that one to the
next sheet and writing that out and then
before you know it you've got your step
by step okay here's what I'm going to do
first here's what I'm going to do second
here's how much money I need for this
for that because you've got a lot of big
things on your plate and I think that's
what's stressing you out somewhere you
know you got and you have at least two
or if not three stages at least to this
plan the 42 year old's the final stage
or the next to final stage you follow me
but the early stage is okay how can I
make more money today doing anything
that is legal and moral that I'm not
ashamed of uh today and that's the short
term because you know if you suddenly
doubled your income right now it would
change your outlook
yeah and that's just doing anything I
mean even it's something you never were
going to do over a 10-year period of
time but for now it gets the wolf away
from the door and then that sets you up
for building a sustainable household
while you execute the long-term plan
so we'll help you with all of that I'm
going to give you everything in sight
because somebody needs to walk with you
you got you got you got hit here hard so
um number one we're going to put you
through Financial Peace University have
you ever done that yet
I have not but I've read your book okay
well you need to go through the
financial base University because it's
gonna it's the system that makes you do
everything like you're going to sell
this truck a 17-5 truck does not fit in
your life
it's too expensive okay you need a cheap
car right now because you're broke
living at home trying to recover from a
divorce with a baby then 17-5 truck is
like rich people stuff you're not there
yet you're going to be there again
someday but right now this truck is too
big a problem
650 payment
about a 300. really 350 for 62 years
okay wow okay cool so anyway yeah the
good okay but anyway yeah we need to get
out of that and get it in the cheapest
possible thing that will get you to your
goals
because we're not care about what we're
driving right now what we're not what
we're doing right now is piling up money
to go hit the goals okay that's
Financial Peace University I'm also
going to give you Ken Coleman's book
from paycheck to purpose and his career
assessment which is a thing to take
about 20 minutes it's going to help
guide you in your career because I'm
still a little bit afraid
you like science you like health care
but I'm not positive
I'd love for you to find a way a path
through your your your gifts and calling
uh that gets you to more money faster
than these long-term education plays are
going to get you to
yeah I don't want to wait five or six
years to start playing this out that's
bothering me with what you're the things
you're proposing I want I want your life
to get better faster than that for you
and so we love you and we want you to
win so you hang on we're going to give
you a Ken Coleman's book we're going to
give you the assessment and we're going
to give you Financial Peace University
all of the above because you got to get
boy this is one where the career is a
big deal it is I do feel like there's
something that she can do in the short
term to really change her income and to
really improve that it's not the
long-term play She's Not Afraid it'll
work no not at all being a server is
about as hard a work as there is no but
doing you're earning a little bit more
is going to help her start to put all of
this into clear focus and see okay how
am I gonna because she can get out of
this debt way quicker than she thinks
because of the truck and then she's
going to be able to start saving up to
move out and then saving up to do the
education piece so I'm not worried about
our current student loan debt I don't
know I didn't even spend her 22 000 yet
yeah because I might want to spend that
on this short-term education play yeah
to go get a couple of certifications of
some kind absolutely to go get a steady
that's paying 40 or 50 and I can get
back on my own get me a little apartment
get started again then I'll start paying
off that debt and start working
long-term plan that's right getting rid
of that she's still she's still just
reeling from the emotions of this and
that makes her just a human being yeah
we all have that yeah ouch
she's doing great though she's gonna
she's gonna see her way out of this when
we were broke I used to make a list what
makes me money by Friday
and that's what I worked on because I
had to have money by Friday I feel that
this is the Ramsay show
[Music]
thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
you probably heard me say this if you've
been listening for very long the Ramsey
did the Ramsey research team did the
largest
detailed in-depth study of millionaires
ever done in North America
we studied 10 167 of them
in depth very careful research
methodology to where there's no question
about the data point being if you
disagree with the conclusions of this
data you're what's known as wrong
yeah we discovered the top five careers
one of these is always controversial
here they are number one career among
millionaires engineer
number two accountant number three
teacher number four Management number
five attorney medical doctors didn't
even make the top five
they came in at number six
teacher teacher teacher you can't be
listen I this is not an opinion and it's
not a Feeling
and it's not an indictment of the fact
that you didn't make it I'm just telling
you of all the millionaires that we
studied the third most common
occupation to appear in the research was
teacher that's just a statistical fact
it's not a statement of what you make or
your friend makes it's just the deal so
not surprising because actually all four
five of those are process oriented
careers they find a proven process and
they use it
every all five of those and that's what
it that's what Building Wealth is a
proven process so in the best-selling
book baby steps millionaires we take a
deep dive into investing wealth building
and busting through the barriers like
lies like believing lies that keep
people from becoming a millionaire
so backed by popular demand baby steps
Millionaires and almost all of our
number one best-selling books are all
ten dollars right now at
ramsaysolutions.com by the way the baby
steps millionaire is book number one
bestseller has the white paper of the
study in the back of it as an appendix
so you get the white paper with it in
one deal we used to sell that separately
for ten dollars now the whole stink of
deal is ten dollars so yeah
ramsesolutions.com hit the store before
this Deal's over and it's just about
over Robert's in Columbus Ohio hey
Robert welcome to the Ramsey Show
hi thank you for taking my call sure
um my wife and I are having a friendly
discussion uh we're both retired we
retired about a year ago oh we're having
a discussion on buying a sort of
expensive new reverses used vehicle and
we both have valid points and I told her
I would uh run it by day and see what he
says I think uh so how much is the truck
oh it's not trucks it's not a truck okay
I thought you almost said truck okay
what is it no it's it's a it's a Lexus
sports coupe
that's a great car I drove that car the
other day that's a great car okay the uh
what is it how much is it 70 or 80 no no
no no no we're looking it's LC 500 we're
probably looking about 115 000. oh you
loaded it up okay wow okay that's a nice
car all right and so what's your net
worth
well that's a thing I think we can well
afford it no what's your net worth
a little over five million dollars buy
the car
okay well it's not a matter of buying a
car it's new versus used
buy new man
thank you let me tell you let me tell
you how I decide that okay here's the
thing here's how you can tell if your
emotions have caught up with your wealth
you use ratios
ratios all right and so you have a five
million dollar net worth you're spending
one hundred thousand dollars or so on a
car
as a ratio if you set fire to that car
with no insurance and it disappeared and
turned into a vapor
your life doesn't even blink
now you have a 4.9 million dollar net
worth whoopty
all right that's the ratio okay now
let's change it around let's say you had
a three hundred thousand dollar net
worth
right now that car goes up into a vapor
you've destroyed one third of your net
worth that's not a ratio that's
acceptable that's stupid
right that's how you use ratios and
that's how you look at it like I got a
buddy that makes 15 million a year he
pulled up the other day in a car that
was 460 000 bucks
and I'm like my mind can't even get
around that
but it's a weird car oh my God it's
fabulous I bet had a crystal ashtray
unbelievable yeah so Robert areas in
that car I know right are you more
excited that you won the argument or
that you get the car
no I'm more excited because I like being
right yeah I knew it I knew it
well that's the reason it's not my point
is it's not it's not foolish yeah the
amount of depreciation difference in the
new are used in this car in your
situation as a ratio is not foolish
okay so it shouldn't even be up for
discussion then yeah it's not not with
your ratios again but if you pull the
numbers down and tighten up those ratios
right then it's different because here's
the other thing you guys are highly
generous people aren't you
yes and so you give away a lot more than
we're talking about
yeah yeah a lot that's how you get to
where you are yeah what'd you do for a
living by the way
uh she's in the medical field and I
owned a small business that both did
you're understating both of those
tremendously okay very well done very
well done so the art of the
understatement this guy yeah so I have a
question that I think that folks
listening would have
when does I mean obviously in his case
his net worth is fine like he can buy a
brand new car at what point does the
rule that we have here
um that we say we don't want your things
that go that have an uh engine in them
we don't want them to be more than 50 of
your take-home pay when your net worth
is so large that it doesn't it doesn't
even matter yeah because your take-home
pay is a good gauge until you've got
like but if you've got a five or ten
million dollar note worth yeah now we're
talking about what percentage because
the reason we tell people that is you're
going to lose so much value yeah so if
you make 70 000 a year and you got fifty
thousand dollars worth of cars sit in
the driveway you're gonna be broke your
whole life that's the definition of I
want to be middle class my whole life
it's true right and so why because 50
000 is going to turn into
twenty thousand in two years Kitty split
okay and you can so you're going to lose
30 000 bucks and you make 70. you can't
afford to lose 30 000 bucks when you
make 70. but let's say you made 70 but
you had a 10 million dollar net worth
now you can afford to lose thirty
thousand bucks because you're retired
and you're living on almost nothing and
you just chose to but you've you know if
you've got a five million dollar net
worth your income if it's at ten percent
is half million dollars a year that's
true
you may not be using the income it may
be rolling back into the investment you
might not be cashing out your retirement
you may be letting it grow right but
your income created by that balance
sheet is larger than your income that is
true whether you're actually pulling
that or not yep so that's the thing to
keep in mind that's why you'll reach a
point that net worth supersedes that and
you know the other thing that comes into
this is the spiritual discussion
Christians should never because we all
know that all Christians should drive a
10 year old Camry I sure hope not
because that's holiness
because you should never have anything
nice what
you should not be out you should not be
out of proportion with your generosity
yeah with your net worth and you know
like I got a buddy of mine that's worth
about three billion he's a huge believer
they give away three to five hundred
million a year and he's he's a known
figure in the Christian World business
guy okay not a minister business guy and
he bought a hundred and eighty thousand
dollar hundred sixty thousand dollar
Mercedes nothing and which as a ratio is
like most people buying a biscuit yeah
but these narrow-minded people that are
oversaved start trashing him on social
media for buying a a car that is a very
small percentage of his world meanwhile
they're deeply in debt and 48 000 pounds
overweight called gluttony and yet
they're managing to call out somebody
else oh Dave you're getting them right
now I mean call out somebody else just
keep calling out somebody else and for
you snowflakes out there everyone that
disagrees with you is not a narcissist
that is gaslighting you you're just a
wuss
so we'll just put that right in the
whole thing there just put that in your
pipe and smoke it mixed in there and
smoke it while you're at it this
is the Ramsay show
[Music]
hey what's up guys it's Jay if you love
the show and want a deeper dive on your
money Journey we have a Weekly
Newsletter that gives you trending and
helpful articles and tips on following
the Ramsay way just go to
ramseysolutions.com today to sign up for
our newsletter again that's
ramsesolutions.com to sign up for our
Weekly Newsletter
[Music]
live from the headquarters of Ramsey
Solutions broadcasting from the pods
removing and storage Studios it's the
Ramsay show where we help people build
wealth do work that they love and create
actual amazing relationships Jade wash
all Ramsay personality is my co-host
today open phones a triple eight eight
two five five two two five Jessica
starts this hour in Salt Lake City hi
Jessica welcome to the Ramsey Show
hey Dave it's a pleasure to speak to you
how are you better than I deserve what's
up in your world oh every life you know
you know aside and I was raised to buy
an investment property before we buy a
house for ourselves you were raised
wrong oh okay well there we go
do we buy a house for ourselves first or
an investment property or do we split
the cash half in half and put it down
the middle buy a house for yourself
first okay that's all we were wondering
what do you have saved we have about
three hundred thousand dollars very good
so what price range home
so yeah so
um that's kind of where we're at and
that's what we're looking for do we if
we put all the money down for an
investment or a house yeah I mean what
price range home
I'm so sorry um we were you know it kind
of we haven't looked too far into it
um where we're at in Salt Lake I feel
like a normal sized house like for a
solid family of like a four bedroom
house starts at about between seven and
eight hundred thousand dollars this
depends on which street you're on yeah
yeah that's true hey um how much do you
guys make a year
um about a hundred thousand dollars good
for you okay let me let me back back
walk the why okay behind our answer
okay okay so personal residence is a key
element paid off of the first one to
five million dollars of net worth that
people build
okay not investment property
okay statistically speaking
okay personal residence that creates a
reasonable standard of living not
necessarily opulence
but certainly not you know living in a
camping trailer out back a Mall's house
okay that's not what we're doing but a
personal residence that gives you a
reasonable sustainable level of standard
of living creates stabilization in your
relationships your health is better
your career has more of a tendency to
prosper the budget prospers because the
largest line item in everyone's personal
budget until they're very wealthy is
their home
okay and uh so when you get control of
the largest line item and stabilize it
by buying a home and or you know paying
cash for it or not but getting it paid
off very very soon you have a higher
tendency to prosper because your health
is better your relationships are better
your career blossoms there's tons of
data around home ownership that
indicates those things
okay so another question for you because
um we're looking into buying a house or
we only so we live in my parents town
home right now and we only spend a
thousand dollars a month on that I also
would feel guilty going out and spending
almost three thousand dollars on a
mortgage compared to where I'm only
spending a thousand dollars a month in
rent but I'm only renting it's not an
asset exactly
okay so you're making a hundred thousand
dollars a year and you buy a home with
three hundred thousand dollars down and
then you map out how quickly we can pay
off that home
okay
and then that because you're you're
probably going to do it in five years
um
I really do I mean like okay so
um probably seven
okay I might be five be between five and
seven but you're making a hundred and of
course you're not five years from now
you're not gonna be making a hundred on
average your income will go up
okay yeah that's true and we're gonna
throw everything we've get that we've
got extra money at this mortgage because
the goal becomes to pay it off because
when you get the house paid off and now
you're making 150 and it's five or six
years from now
um you're still very young to save up
and pay cash for your first investment
property and you're going to do
extremely well
oh I hope so I want to that's my goal
that's I mean we all want to be rich and
famous right I mean maybe not famous but
Jessica you don't have any other debt do
you no no debt I was gonna say that 300
Grand is about it's all of our funds put
together including our mutual funds our
our personal Ira our emergency funds
that's everything yeah you cannot use
retirement money for this down payment
and you have to have your emergency fund
set aside so you're not gonna put down
quite 300 Grand but
um but I'm going to tear into this house
and because you have this big goal of a
paid for house and then a paid for
investment property yeah and let's hit
this again real quick because I don't
know how much money she has outside of
the retirement money that she was
talking about using so let's be really
clear Jessica about that don't touch
those retirement funds and make sure
that that's going to change the equation
a little bit for you so make sure that
whatever you purchase it's no more than
25 of your take-home pay and of course
you're doing that 15-year fixed rate
mortgage and given this discussion I
mean Salt Lake is not a hyper cheap
environment but it's also not a hyper
expensive yeah so given this discussion
you may want to actually look at 500
instead of 700 yeah absolutely I just
depending on how much you're putting as
a downstroke yeah because again
you know well this is my forever house
there's no such thing except heaven
there is no forever house about the only
thing you can count on is you're going
to move that's right you know I just
don't know how quick or where but you're
gonna move I always say forever home
that's a slippery slope when people say
things like forever home for me Dave
that means they're giving themselves
permission to spend more that's what
that crazy forever wife
I have a forever Jesus nothing else I
got's forever
everything else goes away
because I told Sharon I mean we've been
married 41 years I told her if she
leaves I'm going with her so
that's how that works open phones at
triple eight eight two five five two two
five
guys one of the things about personal
finance and it's Illustrated in the
answer to that question is that it's
as much personal as it is finance and if
you try to correct things that have
anxiety and spiritual principles and
relationship issues
you try to manage those things with math
they never work so a stable Home
Presence
castle for you to come home to after
you've been working hard a safe haven an
emotionally calm place
that's good to reset and go fight again
another day has tied with it actual
income
absolutely
that's absolutely the case and you know
I think that people I think that's why
Dave so many people want to get to that
step so quickly even if it means getting
to it the wrong way you know we know it
but we don't know why we know it we kind
of know it in our nowhere that's right
yeah deep down deep down in our nowhere
yeah that's exactly right but yeah it's
and you're right it can cause people to
short-circuit it but I I think sometimes
we're always going I got to buy a house
because houses go up in value and I
don't want to be left out in the market
let's see that's all math and that's not
considering that your stress level goes
down so your your medical condition is
better it versus not being there because
you know when you got to deal with all
this other stuff man I don't know that's
true this is the Ramsay show
[Music]
[Applause]
buying a home is one of the biggest
decisions of your life you need a
partner like Churchill Mortgage
Churchill is one of the highest rated
lenders in the country and their Ramsay
trusted because they do what's right for
you Churchill works with you to build a
mortgage the Ramsey Way one that doesn't
bust your budget sets you up for
financial success and helps you get out
of debt faster go to
churchillmortgage.com today and get
started
[Music]
thank you
Jade warshaw Ramsey personality is my
co-host today thank you for joining us
America
so Jade you're doing your own Financial
Peace University class and you're not by
yourself affirmative I and Rachel Cruz
are also doing a class hers is both of
ours have started they started May 8th
but all the personalities are doing
classes so you could go to a Financial
Peace University class with Dr John
deloney yes and you should his class is
actually coming up next uh and you
should sign up for his class and then
after that George Campbell yeah George
Campbell Kim Coleman Eddie Cohen Eddie
Cullen yeah everybody's doing a class
everybody changing their lives love it
very cool so if you don't know what
Financial face University is you haven't
been listening for very long because
it's the best thing we do around here
it's nine lessons and you go through it
with a coordinator in person or
virtually online with a coordinator and
the coordinator is the one that guides
you and loves you and holds you
accountable and encourages you when
you're scared and holds you accountable
when you're about to screw up because
you think you got this figured out if
you had it figured out what are you
doing in a financial class so hey we're
here to help you we know what to do and
we've LED 10 million people out of debt
and into wealth 10 million people have
been through this class
that makes it the largest personal
finance class in North America ever
I suggest I mean there's a lot of ways
that you can take the class but I
suggest taking it with Community I
always got to be with communities you're
the head of your community exactly the
Jade Community check it out if you want
to go through with one of the
personalities you can still get signed
up Financial Peace University at
ramseysolutions.com or go to fpu.com
either one Abby is with us in San
Francisco hey Abby what's up
hi good afternoon Dave and James
um so I'm concurrency on baby step 3B
and um I just feel guilty if I budget to
spend money on vacation so like then I
just never do and I spend it on like
other necessities instead
just because I don't want to slow down
saving money and I just want to get past
this block
I mean that's if you're saving for a
home and you're foregoing certain
expenditures because you want to say
faster that is your prerogative and I
don't think there's anything wrong with
that especially when you're in those
first three baby steps I mean you're
looking at the situation you've got a
set of scales in front of you and you go
on one side of the scales as a vacation
on the other side of the scales is I get
to buy my house faster and I'm choosing
to buy my house faster that's not Guild
I sure made a choice
yeah I I understand but I also feel like
um I feel like this is going to continue
once I do get the house I'll be like oh
I need to pay it off and I just want to
like I listen to what you said and I you
I said you allocate a percentage to
spending and enjoyment but I just feel
like I just never do it are you married
are you married
no I'm single so this is what do you
make
can I make 120 what are you talking
about allocating for a vacation that you
wouldn't do
uh maybe like
2 500 or 3 000 then it'll go up as my
network increases of course so I think I
think the point is this what you need to
do also is to put uh actual you're
dealing with feelings which are okay to
admit we have feelings that's not a bad
thing but you need to put the actual
numbers to it and go okay if I spend two
grand on this vacation how much does it
really damage
my goal of setting a house
mathematically okay I mean I've already
saved fifty thousand I'm probably going
to save another forty thousand or
whatever the number is how much is 2 000
really going to blow it up now if you
said I'm going to spend 20 grand on
vacation then I would say plus back that
down you know because it's probably
going to use up a whole bunch of your
savings but usually if you put actual
math to it and go is this really keeping
me from hitting the goal mm-hmm
yeah it's not
yeah and then that's going to help you
with all the other stages as well you
see he seems like a formula driven guy
or like a I just go you go in steps and
I feel like he just needs to almost like
he said he just when the time comes he's
got to make it part of his plan well
allocate a non-damaging percentage of
your savings to enjoyment yeah not house
not house and a non-damaging percentage
it's good for the mental health to get
away every once in a while a b so so add
that to the list
all right let's go to Justin in Grand
Rapids hey Justin what's up
guys thank you so much for taking my
call sure so my question for today is um
my wife and I are on baby six uh baby
steps uh four through six and we just
decided to tackle our mortgage and to
get it out
um we have a couple businesses that we
have um the house that we're living in
is a duplex so we have the rental income
and that side of the business and then
we live off of my wife's full-time
business as a Potter and so my question
is how much do we allocate do we have 42
000 sitting in a bank how much do we
allocate to throw at the mortgage and to
get that out of here as soon as possible
um and then how much do we set aside for
the two businesses of the Pottery
business and the duplex
this is interesting so you've got tell
me how much money you have again I was
taking all of that in forty two thousand
forty two thousand now is this how much
is owed on the duplex
uh just under three hundred thousand and
what do you make a year
I'll sold it how should we taxable
income
about 50 after taxes and business
expenses
and her business is successful
and why do you not make money
uh I'm a stay-at-home dad with our kids
and then I'm also doing whatever side
hustles and remote contract work that I
can on the side
okay
and so her Pottery business is making
thirty five thousand
uh it's making 36 uh gross thousand but
the expenses are extremely low because
it's just the pottery cost okay you
don't need an emergency fund for it and
we certainly don't need one for your
other business it doesn't make any money
at all
yeah well the uh right yeah for me
personally but then it's mostly like how
much do we have all the duplex you said
you don't need you don't need a huge
emergency fund for the duplex we just
need to start working to get it out of
debt so you make fifty thousand dollars
a year you have a three hundred thousand
dollar mortgage and how many kids
uh we have two kids four and one years
old okay
all right
uh the thing that's missing in the
equation that's glaring is your income
is low
your household income is low that's the
number that feels out of whack when I
hear your story
so what's the plan
uh I have been working as many side
houses as we can we've been working on
my wife's uh business every year it's
growing by about 50 percent of its
previous year's income it's only about
three four years old
um and so yeah we're just working as as
hard as we can as well as
um you know taking care of the kids and
that sort of thing
is there anything more that you can do
to add to the equation
I mean picking up more hours more side
hustles that sort of thing yeah okay all
right well I I you know I think that's
what you got to map out here because
that's a bigger question than
um out of your 42 000 you should set us
at an emergency fund of three to six
months of household expenses you don't
have any debt except the house right
correct we are completely debt-free
um except for the mortgage and we
already have so what do you think three
to six months of expenses for your
emergency fund is
uh well we have 18 000 allotted for our
personal oh in addition to the 42. okay
that's good so 42 is just sitting in our
bank in high yield savings account until
we decide what we're doing with it um
essentially and do we need any of that
to grow her business aggressively
no we we don't because it's just her and
then because I have one employee but
it's um yeah but if you double you said
it doubled in the last three years if it
doubles again you're going to need some
help
true true
I mean you may need another you may need
another killing
I feel like I'm just thinking about your
situation and the money you have saved
in your personal and the money you have
set aside from this business money I
feel like I would keep I would want you
to have six months of expenses because
of the nature of what you do I also
would like you to sit on a large portion
of what you already have saved from the
business because you've got a duplex
and I feel like that could come with a
lot of cost maybe you keep 20 000 of it
aside yeah I think I'm gonna put another
20 with that 18 and then throw the other
23 at your house yeah and but I think
and make sure that you really thought
out the pro forma for growing your
businesses and where you're going to end
up here because that you may need some
of that money to do that with because
I'm more concerned about getting your
income up in this equation than I am
what happens to this little twenty
thousand dollars towards your mortgage
this is the Ramsey Show
[Music]
we've been doing business at Ramsey for
more than 30 years by now we're a
well-oiled machine but it wasn't always
that way yes we've always had a vision
always had determination and a drive to
help people but what we didn't have was
one central place to access all our
numbers so that we could get further
ahead or quickly see when we needed to
Pivot we were always jumping back and
forth between different systems and
spreadsheets so when netsuite by Oracle
helped us Wrangle our Revenue inventory
expenses and more into one place it was
a game changer and netsuite's number one
Cloud Financial system can help your
business gain the same visibility
because businesses thrive on timely data
and next week's real-time analytics can
help your business have immediate access
to your numbers daily so you always know
where you stand and you can move quickly
so go to netsuite.com Ramsey today and
set up a free product tour that's
netsuite.com Ramsey
[Music]
thank you
Jade warshaw Ramsey personality is my
co-host today the phone number here is
triple eight eight two five five two two
five thank you for joining us Jacob is
next in Kansas City hi Jacob welcome to
the Ramsey Show
hi Dave hundred pleasure talking to you
guys you too
so
um I got a lot of moving pieces on my
financial chess board right now
um and my wife and I feel like we're
doing all the right things
um but we're also talking about having
our first kid next year trying trying to
have our first kid next year and I just
want to make sure that I yes thank you I
mean we're excited just talking about it
but
um we want to make sure that we're
prioritizing the right things to not
only set up for sustained Success
Through that life change but also
ideally maybe allowing my wife to switch
to part-time she's she's an RN so you
know being able to go part-time would
allow for more time with the hopeful
Future kid
you're gonna be a good dad that's
exciting you're actually thinking about
it wow who knew and um yeah very cool so
what do you make
uh our combined no you income last year
no you oh me uh
um 75 to 80 right now okay
how old are you
I'm 27. how much debt have you all got
uh other than our mortgage nothing wow
great job can you live on 80. thank you
you know
we hadn't fully considered that
um we we bought our house last year uh
I've been paying
close to 200 extra per month straight to
principal trying to you know pay down
that that mortgage early
um and you know we just I mean we
haven't been maxing our Roth IRAs what
does she make I have not maximized
um she made 55 to 60 our combined is
about 135.
so no debt how much do you have left on
the house is that your goal that you
want to have that house paid off before
she would go to part-time or stay at
home is that the goal or
that's just what you've been trying to
do I realistically don't think that's
possible I am just trying to get ahead
of the curve and you know build a habit
that will allow us to continue I mean
we're already well I think you're ahead
we've been in it a year so you know yeah
you're ahead of the curve in the way
that you don't have debt and that you're
on a plan which is good and you've got
three to six months saved I'm assuming
uh yeah we have about 18 000 in a high
yield savings
okay so here's the deal uh what will she
make if she goes part-time
um that's the great thing uh if she goes
to night shift and she's finishing her
bachelor's this December uh her pay
virtually won't change well there you go
then there's not a question
this is a no-brainer it's not but that's
honestly we were wanting to avoid that
um and so I'm wanting to avoid her
working at all
no avoid her having to work night shift
um
[Music]
that makes sense yeah I don't argue that
all right so what can she make if she
works not working the night shift
part-time
um it it would be probably about a 20 to
000 estimated pay cut
so you guys are remind me what she makes
again
um 55 to 60 last time okay so let's
let's call it 40.
okay and you make 80. that's 120.
start living on 120 now and have babies
go
Ready set go okay
easy it's it's easy I love these calls
because he has options he's made it to
where he can sit and decide do I want to
do this do I want to do that and in this
case it's really cool because I kind of
feel like you thought Jacob that we were
gonna lay out this plan white you know
as to where you can't do what you want
to do but you've set yourself a fabulous
one if you want to live on 80 she can
just quit that too
which they could do I mean they just
have their house payment
that's what the Ramses did yeah and it
wasn't 80. I can tell you that
and if she wanted to also 38 years ago
but yeah there's that but yeah after a
certain period of time maybe she wants
to go back to work again maybe she
doesn't yeah you know make sure to keep
those shirts up if you're a nurse for
sure if you go the trouble to get that
keep those certifications in place and
his income is going to go up over time
as well absolutely you guys have done
great you've done great
so yeah if everybody waited until they
could afford to have kids they would
never have kids facts man
and the best thing ever happened to Dave
Ramsey's babies except possibly
grandbabies
if I don't know how great grandbabies
are going to be I'd have been nicer to
their parents okay Sarah's with us in
Minneapolis hi Sarah welcome to the
Ramsey Show
hey guys cash is King that is dumb love
ya love it love it how can we help
uh so I'm calling because my husband and
I
um were on baby step two we're hammering
out
um the debt as we make extra money and
picking up extra shifts at the hospital
my husband uh Paul snow in the winter so
he makes every time doing that and all
of it's been going to debt or things
that have come up that we could cash
flow
um but right now we're wondering if we
should sell our townhouse and
um take that money pay off school loans
fully fund our emergency fund and um
just rent until we could save up the 20
for a new home what do you owe on the
townhouse and what could you get for it
uh so we owe about 100 on townhouse and
the last we checked was a couple months
ago and they said we could get around 2
30 for it
and school under 70 000.
so have you priced out if you were to
you know go from your living situation
now to renting how is that going to
change your monthly payment
um the rent would be a little bit more
because our mortgage as well
um but
if we didn't have any debt because the
only debt we have we put our camper up
for sale and then we have school loans
um and hopefully our camper will sell
we're like
just praying it will it sell for it
would be what are you asking for it
um we're asking 23 for it okay and how
much do you owe on it
20 20. okay so it's not gonna help other
school levels at all
no well you just get rid of the payment
yes yes it would get rid of the yeah
what's your household income
uh we make about 130 a year keep the
townhouse
you haven't been doing this very long
no we have not no yeah you just got
started and you realize this is hard
yeah it is hard uh yeah we paid off
about
it yeah and then when you sell the
camper you're gonna pay off another 23
and then you make 130 and you only got
70 left just knock it out
I agree with that yeah well we we were
hoping that we'd sell the camper but
but chaos school loans fully fund our
emergency fund yeah and then you're out
of the real estate business and you've
got an expensive rent no I'm gonna sit
in the townhouse let it go up in value
while you clean up the rest of this mess
exactly okay ounce is not your problem
the camper is a problem
oh for sure that's why it's for sale
um I mean we were kind of thinking what
you said but I don't know the appeal of
not having any debt and the appeal of
doing this fast and easy it's not fast
or easy either one and it's not the
smartest Choice even money-wise because
like Dave said you're in the real estate
market which is where so many people
want to be and if you just sit on that
property long enough it's going to be
worth something when you're actually
ready to go and buy a full-sized house
and right now I think what Dave said man
Dave that's so true it's hard to pay off
debt it's hard to walk through that
process and I think a lot of times when
people get into this they're looking for
what's the Quick Fix what can I sell how
can I get out of this fast and although
wanting to pay off your debt fast is a
good thing you've got to think about
what you're selling when it comes to
your house if it's really the wisest
Choice long term or not in this case I
don't think it is I think they've got a
good income and I think if they put the
pedal to the metal they can pay off
their debt quicker than they realized
it's fun when you see all the
information and you go I can do this and
you got all this enthusiasm and then you
go about three months in you go crap
I'm more picking up extra shifts at the
hospital we're not going out to eat
tired I'm tired this is hard the kids
are whiny yeah this is hard yeah it is
hard but you know what over the scope of
your life the two years it's going to
take you to get out of debt when you saw
this camper it's really not much it's
very hard but sir you got what it takes
to do it I'm proud of you you can do
this
this is the Ramsey Show
[Music]
foreign
thank you for joining us America
Jade and I were just out of the
commercial break if you want to and
you're coming through Nashville stop by
and watch the show we do it on the glass
from one to four central time every
Monday through Friday there are two of
us Ramsey personalities sitting in here
doing the show it's sometimes like
watching ugly paint dry but it's it's uh
you can come and we would love to have
you there's usually just a handful of
people out here today but there's
usually 50 to 200 folks come by the
coffee is free the cookies are free and
I got to talk to a young couple just now
when we were out there getting our
pictures done with them said you changed
our life well of course we didn't change
their life we just told them how and
they changed their lives that's what we
do we tell you how and you are the hero
and you get to win you get to go slay
the dragon we just give you dragon
slaying instructions and then you have
to go kill the dragon and you can do it
and we'll show you how we have and thank
you for that by the way if you're happy
with the dragon slaying instructions if
you've liked this show so far we'd
appreciate some help uh subscribe to the
show if you are watching on YouTube hit
the Subscribe button or follow button or
whatever's appropriate with the type of
podcast you're on
um make sure it's dialed into your car
radio if you're a talk radio listener
thank you for that and this preset is
done there just number one preset that's
where you put it right there push that
memory button some of you don't even
know how to do that I was going to say
do that do the cars still have that they
still got it I promise you and the uh
might not have a CD player but they got
that and uh in addition to that of
course we'd appreciate it if you would
share the show share a link or hit the
share button if there is one or just
tell people where you're listening and
have them come join us and leave a five
star review those help with the
algorithm on the internet as well uh one
Stars aren't helpful if you don't like
the show why are you spending your time
here that's a good go somewhere else and
just move on mama said if you ain't got
anything nice to say don't say nothing
at all there you go there's a plan so
you live as a five star share it follow
it subscribe it whatever it is and all
of those things help us a bunch and help
us help more people we appreciate that
very very much Dixie's in Savannah
Georgia that's apropos hi Dixie how are
you
I'm good how are you better than I
deserve what's up
um so so mom um she's 59 years old
she's gonna be trying to get in
retirement soon but she doesn't have
anything safe for retirement
um she currently has about 20K left on
her mortgage she has student loans she
has 18K how much in student loans
that I'm not too sure how old did you
say five nine or six nine
okay
yes sir did you guess how much she had
on her student loans if you had to guess
uh maybe about 35
000 okay
we'll call it that for discussion
purposes how can we help okay
um so my mom her mindset is is your
everybody is going to be in bed and
there's no way around it and I've come
across you guys for maybe about a year
now I have The Total Money Makeover book
I tried to offer her to read it but
she's not she's not a big reader
um so every time I get a chance I try to
sit down with her and talk to her about
different things that I feel would be
beneficial for her and she'll sit and
she'll listen but I think maybe because
in her mind I'm young and I'm not wise
and I'm not I don't know what I'm
talking about she'll listen for a few
minutes and then she's like oh you know
I don't think that that's you know the
best way for me to handle something so
my my question to you guys is how could
I help guide my mom to better set her up
for retirement I'm sorry this sucks I I
I hate this for you you know you you're
the kid and you've got hold of this
thing that you know can help her and
she's just yeah she I'm just gonna be
honest she's still in that childlike
phase where she wants her what she wants
and she's gonna do what she's gonna do
and I'll be honest with you you're not I
hate to tell you this you're not going
to be the one to convince her otherwise
probably true right we call it the
powdered butt syndrome once someone has
powdered your butt they don't care about
your opinion on sex or money
right so she doesn't she doesn't think
that she's headed towards Calamity
clearly if she's retiring now at 59 with
her if she does you think she doesn't
believe there's hope yeah
Dixie what I and the only luck I have
ever had is one of two things
um number one you can't talk to her
about her situation at all that will not
work you've tried that occasionally okay
what you can talk about is your
situation
and your feelings you know Mom I used to
believe I was gonna die in debt I
thought I was going to be in debt my
whole life and you know what I'm almost
out
and I did this stuff and it made me feel
so good it's been hard but it's been
worth it and it's the first time in my
life I've Got Confidence about money My
Hope factor is so high right now but boy
I used to really think I was never going
to be able to win I thought I'd be in
debt my whole life and um man Mom it's
just a lot of fun all you talk about is
you and pretty soon she'll catch herself
bragging to her friends you know my
daughter Dixie she's getting out of debt
and then as soon as she starts saying
stuff like that she's going to go hmm
I wonder if I should
but you can you could it is not it is
never offensive
for you to talk about you
okay but um
you know if uh
like I got a guy in the in the on our
company here that lost uh he's one of
our uh software engineers and he lost
like 60 something pounds
and I went up to him I'm like man
what in the world
that's amazing I mean you lost like a
backstreet boy I mean this is crazy you
know and he's like yeah I said man I'm
so proud of you his shoulders kicked
back his chest stuck out how'd you do
that I ate less it's amazing
and he didn't come up to me and go you
know Dave you could lose 25 pounds you
feel a lot better Dave if you'd get out
of the donuts I'm not in the donuts
anymore but he didn't come up to me and
do that right he just came up to me and
he stood there as this walking
testimony that his new way of life is
causing him to be able to feel better
and be healthier right that's a
wonderful thing the second thing other
than you talking about you is if you
know someone that she respects in the
area of business and money you might
talk to them because she might listen to
them if you put them on her
right so Uncle so and so has always been
Noel you know Harry he's always had
money he's good with money well go tell
Harry to go talk to her right what do
you think what do you think she'd say if
you said hey Mom I I found out about
this Financial Peace University class
I'm gonna take it do you want to take it
with me what do you think she'd say
I feel like if I was I was taking it and
I offered her to go I feel as though she
would go
um yeah but you got to be real careful
not to talk ever during the whole class
say anything about her you know saying
you just say I'm doing this for me and
at the end except for encouraging her
yeah but never like Mom you got to get
this straight it's like you're gonna you
got you better get desperate no you
don't you are not her accountability
that will not work it's like when you
take a friend to church and the pastor
is speaking you don't go that's for you
yeah that's for you here you're talking
to you can you hear him and you know
what I'm saying you can't do that right
it's just sit be quiet and that's it you
know that's a good point that's very
right you know that's very good I think
that's what you that's what I would take
away from this I would I'd say Mom I'm
signing up for Financial Peace
University I've got to get a couple of
things right you know I've been
listening to the show hey you know I've
got two free passes I appreciate it if
you go with me because I think you'd be
I think you'd be an encouragement to me
oh that's good right there
but don't you dare say a word about her
stuff that's right if she brings it up
you just smile and Nod and say Mom I
think you can win that's all you can say
but you can't say that you know
you can't think that way because it
doesn't work it just doesn't work right
that's good well I appreciate that yeah
this is tough I'm proud of you for
calling in I'm proud of you for getting
your own situation intact that's
exciting yeah good for you and uh hey
let's uh Austin can we give them
Financial Peace University
we'll give it to you for free now she
can't turn it down
there you go thank you I appreciate it
yeah let's let's do it call back and
tell us how it goes yeah we want to hear
when you're dead free and moms win and
everybody's on the same page now and all
that yeah it's it's you know it's weird
though that when we're talking with
family we feel like we can
bypass this persuasion step and just go
straight to the your stupid step yes you
know and you got to persuade family like
anybody else because they're grown-ups
they get to do what they want to do
that's true you have to use persuasion
especially if they're your Elder oh for
sure for sure yeah yeah you know sure ah
that puts this hour the Ramsay show in
the books
[Music]
Dave here you can find all of our shows
with the Ramsay Network app on your
smartphone it's the only place to listen
to the entire back catalog of episodes
download the Ramsay Network app in your
favorite app store today
[Music]
thank you
live from the headquarters of Ramsay
Solutions broadcasting from the PODS
moving and storage and Studios it's the
Ramsay show where we help people
build wealth do work
that they love and create actual amazing
relationships Jade warshaw Ramsey
personality is my co-host today the
phone number is triple eight eight two
five five two two five Jenny is in
Orange County starting off this hour hi
Jenny welcome to the Ramsay show
hi Mr Ramsey thank you so much for
taking our call
I just wanted to
say first of all thank you so for your
show and for the advice that you give
thanks to you you've helped us to be out
of debt our home is paid off wow and um
yes good for you way to go so thank you
you're 100 debt free baby step seven
yes sir
[Music]
what's this house in Orange County
called California worth
um I think if you were to go on a
website that would probably list at
about between 1.4 or 1.5 yeah
I'm proud of you
thank you our question is were both in
our mid-50s like I said our home is paid
off we have no debt and we're fairly new
Ramsay followers and we feel like even
though we've started a little bit late
towards savings for retirement we're
maxing out in terms of our 401K backdoor
Roth uh Beyond 15
but we have about 25 000 discretionary
beyond the savings beyond our emergency
savings and we feel like
we've put off for so long some
non-urgent house repairs
sensing maybe a possible car purchase
replacing a nearly 30 year old
refrigerator
us about guilt-free spending now
because we feel that it's
when you think about retiring in Orange
County it seems like the cost of living
is just so high that um should we just
be constantly saving towards it like the
way we've been trying to be out of debt
or now can we take a deep breath and
start putting some money into non-saving
I think that you can take a deep breath
I think that you've done so so so so
very well and that you need to
internalize that you've done well you've
paid off your debt you've paid off your
home and you're in your mid-50s and
you're doing just exactly what you're
supposed to be doing which is now you
are able to chunk more money into
retirement and you're doing that are you
maxing out those accounts
we are we've already maxed out for the
Roth uh for our IRAs we do as much as we
can for our 401k and we're even doing
back door rocks yes because we feel we
have extras to throw at it how much do
you have in retirement savings right now
um uh we were starting late right now in
cash that we have invested we have about
a hundred and fifty but my husband is
works for the state
and has about could count on about 630
for a lump sum payout in lieu of a
pension if we were to choose that option
so total we feel we could have about 750
and our in your household income is what
uh a short of a hundred closer to 95.
okay so let's call it a hundred thousand
dollars a year and you have a two and a
half million dollar net worth and you're
in your fifties
it's called buy a new refrigerator today
go buy a refrigerator every day buy or
buy whatever one you want anything you
want
yeah I guess we're thinking oh my gosh
when we still have about we'd like to
have close to about a million dollars
before you're gonna have you'll be yeah
you're gonna have
you've got the 650 look yeah yes 100 how
old are you 55
we're in our mid 50s yes so the house is
going to go up in value the current
amounts you're putting in are going to
go up in value uh the pension is going
to go up in value less but it will still
go up in value before he cashes it out
but the uh all of that's going to
continue to increase and so you know
when you're 65 you're probably looking
at about a 10 million dollar net worth
at the current track you're on
okay it says it's feel like it
this wasn't a feeling this was
mathematics
have you ever sat down and just played
with a investment calculator just to see
how the numbers go
absolutely and I'll be honest with you
we are very very late to investing
that's why I want you to do this I want
you to when you get off the phone I want
you to just Google go on Ramsay
Solutions I don't want you to go on a
spending splur you didn't get elected to
congress okay you're not gonna go crazy
but buying a refrigerator is not going
to mess you up when you have a two and a
half million dollar net worth
okay buying a better car is not going to
mess you up putting some money into this
and updating the house a little bit is
not going to mess you up all of that
together is less than a hundred thousand
dollars isn't it
refrigerator plus Car Plus home repair
is less than a hundred thousand yes or
no
did I lose her
I think you might have lost her I think
I lost her well it I'll answer your
question the answer is yes Dave and yes
and it's going to break it's not gonna
break her world yeah she's gonna be just
fine play with an investment calculator
people if you've never done that it is
so good for your mind because we're
sitting here telling you the numbers but
to see for yourself what happens when
you put certain amounts away for certain
periods of time it's just good for your
brain to see that yeah yeah so yeah
again
the normal process is that you move from
unaware of how stupid you've been me I
remember that process myself
to going oh God I'm the dumbest human on
the planet I've messed this up I'll
never recover I've got to go crazy and
you go crazy for a period of years
gazelle intense beans and rice rice and
beans you're totally game on we're not
we're not going on vacation we're not
eating out we're getting this mess
cleaned up and because your body is
running at that rate your metabolism is
running at that rate then it's hard to
slow down when you come through that and
and because when you come through being
debt free other than the house and then
you come through getting the house paid
off
you look up and you go wow
wow and and you're breathing a little
differently and then it takes a little
while for your emotions to catch up with
the actual reality of your new math
where you've ended up yes because that
old person it's like that old person
still lives inside of you and you have
to persuade them that things are okay
now yeah
and you know and it's weird because you
had to persuade the stupid person yes
earlier that they're not okay yes you
know right this sucks and you're like
I'm okay with sucks no you're not be Stu
don't be stupid get with it go go go go
go go go go go go go go go go go go
clean the mess up but then when you get
the other side of it you got to look up
and go okay what's the math telling me
that's right I can afford to go on
vacation what's the math telling me I
can afford to upgrade the car what's the
math telling me I'm getting rid of a 30
year old refrigerator
please do it please God that's awful
this is the Ramsay show
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
personality is my co-host today Debbie
is with us in Charlotte North Carolina
hi Debbie welcome to the Ramsay show
for taking my call sure what's up
my husband and I have two grown children
our daughter is married and rents a home
independently our son is also grown but
he lives with us but he does pay rent
they both would love to be able to find
homes of their own they've been unable
to do that because of the market and
just their personal finances they would
love to live close to us as we would
love for them to live close to us as
well
so in November some land came available
some acreage came available very close
to us and my husband and I bought it our
home was paid for but we used an old
HELOC that we had there to purchase the
land because we didn't have enough cash
to buy it outright
so since then
um the rates on the HELOC have more than
doubled which means our payment has more
than doubled
um the kids would still we all still
feel the same we all still love for
everybody to be able to build or do
something out there on that land but
financially they're just not ready so my
question is do we refinance this because
the land is paid for but now we're back
in the mortgage situation
um so do we recently and sister we roll
it into a fixed rate mortgage and just
work at paying it off or
do we sell it wow
what is the land worth
two hundred thousand how big is your
HELOC
uh
uh why did you borrow 50 more than the
land was worth to buy the land when the
house that was just that was a like a
business expense
and the land may be worse than that one
I'm sorry a business expense what do you
mean
we have um
a handyman service and the truck that we
use died and so we did use it for that
okay
so you bought a 50 000 truck that you
couldn't afford you bought a 50 000
truck that you couldn't afford and you
bought a 200 000 piece of ground you
couldn't afford
could we not afford it since our home
was paid for it you know the money to
pay for it by definition that means you
couldn't pay afford it if you didn't
have the money to pay for it your your
business is not making enough money to
justify a fifty thousand dollar truck
you know I know that because you didn't
have fifty thousand dollars
yes we did
we did why did you borrow money then
taxes
taxes what's taxes mean
well I mean
if we had no tax deductions then we're
paying more and more and more and more
in taxes do you not know how a tax
deduction works
if you write off ten thousand dollars it
saves you twenty five hundred dollars
you have to give the bank ten thousand
to keep from sending the government 2500
you don't go in debt to create a tax
deduction that's trading a dollar for a
quarter
okay okay um yeah you need to sell the
land
so we've
done they don't get a vote they're broke
okay so we just need to say
sorry we made a mistake we're gonna sell
it that's right because they can't
afford to buy a house this whole this
whole thing that you guys have concocted
not it's not working it's not real yeah
it's not real you've gone into debt for
this you've got bad practices and then
it's all on the stream that the kids are
gonna one day build houses on this land
but you've said they're not ready to no
one is ready and financially able to do
any of the things none of you speaking
about you're not and they're not
and so this is a wish it's not a it's
not a realistic prognosis and if you're
sitting on three or four million dollars
and you wanted to play this out then I
would just question whether you're being
an enabler for kids that aren't handling
money well but beyond that we don't even
need to get to that because none of the
three of you have the money to do this
deal and I'll tell you what the next
step was Dave The Next Step was they
would have financed those down payments
for those kids if they could yeah that's
where this is that's where it's headed
heading worse yeah yeah gotta let it go
I'm sorry uh I would not have uh a
mortgage on my home for a piece of land
ever but I for sure wouldn't in this
situation
because it's not got this
family compound dream is probably never
going to happen and if it does it's 10
or 15 years from now and
um it's just not it's not a process you
the kids are going to be much better off
to learn to build themselves a
self-sustaining life without mommy and
daddy doing it
and just live nearby that's right all of
my kids live within uh I don't know 30
or 40 minutes of me
um but they don't live in my backyard
none of them would want to probably but
um well there's a certain amount of
pressure that she's that they're placing
on the kids when you say hey I bought
this tract of land then there's also
this okay I guess family
you know I've got I've worked through
several family compound issues over the
years and I don't want one because
here's what happens divorce yeah and now
the ex-daughter-in-law is your next door
neighbor because your son lost the
divorce oh I didn't even think about
that that's terrible that's not good mom
you know uh we gotta offer to make a
half a million dollars a year more in
Seattle so we are leaving Charlotte
that's what I'm saying and uh guess what
you sell that house to who uh stranger
yeah in the family compound some of
those strangers are strange yeah strange
strangers and you get a strange stranger
as your next door neighbor right and
then now now you know Thanksgiving
really tastes different now I'm just
telling you that these things don't end
well I there some people pull it off but
I'm I've just seen all the messes and
that's if this worked and if you guys
weren't broke Debbie but y'all are broke
it doesn't work none of you've got the
money to pull this off you couldn't even
buy a 50 000 or you could buy a 50 000
truck but you didn't so by the way take
the 50 000 from your business that you
had to buy the truck with and pay down
the home equity loan so that when the
land sells it pays off the rest of it
and put the land on the market I don't
think mama's gonna do that I don't think
she's gonna do it either but it's the
right thing to do it is shouldn't have
called here if you didn't want the truth
because we love you so much we do we
want the best for you we're going to
tell you the truth yeah we'll get rid of
that devastating truth tellers Tim's in
Boise hi Tim how are you
hi Dave hi Jade thanks for having me on
sure what's up
um my question is
my wife and I signed three-year
contracts we are both veterinarians
um we work for the same business same
privately owned business and our
contract ends in about 12 13 months
it's been a pretty toxic work
environment been a really rough two
years for us so we're planning to not
resign
and we are 50 of the vet Force at our
clinic so you know where you're going to
land
at this point
um we have a couple ideas a little
closer to family okay oh so you're going
to make a move from a different city
yes it will it will be a move across the
state okay and you think you can you're
going to open a practice or buy into a
practice or what
to get a full-time position as an
associate okay all right cool
all right yeah so what's your question I
have a question I have is
how do we go about when and how to tell
our bosses we're not planning to resign
you know they have quite a bit of power
complex where we're concerned that
they're going to make our lives pretty
miserable
if we tell them too soon but we don't we
want to be ethical about it you know we
don't have to necessarily I don't make
my decisions based on them I make my
decisions based on me
okay and what I do is I treat a business
ethics is answered by one thing almost
always do unto others you should have
them do unto you treat other people like
you'd want to be treated if the roles
were reversed
and you had a team member that thought
you were a jerk
what would you want that team member to
when would you want that team member to
tell you
the answer is today
I would I would sit down with them
before the week was over and say this
simple we're planning at the end of our
contract to move back and be near family
and so I wanted to give you as much
notice as I could so that we could be as
helpful as we can be in the transition
okay that's simple this is you being
classy they choose not to be classy then
you may have to make a decision to leave
early
if they're going to be out of control
because I'm not going to be abused in a
work situation
you take that contract and use it for
toilet paper I'm not gonna stick around
so but hopefully you can create a classy
situation but this is about you having
class not about them yeah you can't
control what they're going to do and
they're probably going to act up let's
be honest kind of know they're going to
that's why we're leaving
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
personality is my co-host today thank
you for joining us America
well the stock market's been rough
lately it's been up it's been down and
it's basically about where it was a year
ago
but it was a wild ride to get to even
the facts are if you invest 200 a month
from age 25 to age 65. you'll have
between a million and two million
dollars
no that's not too good to be true that's
based on the long-term average return of
the s p 500.
now if you're not 25 well that's okay
you can still get started a huge
predictor of investing success is that
you actually invest
yeah so get a pro in your corner to help
you get started
go to ramseysolutions.com smartvester
our smart investor Pros are people that
have the heart of a teacher do things
the way that we teach around here they
don't work for us but we recommend them
I'll drop down a a list of the
smartvestor pros in your area you can
meet with all the different ones and
decide which one you want which one you
uh match up with the best you pick
ramseysolutions.com
smartvester they'll guide you through
the ups and the Downs of the market
Louise is in New York City hi Louise
welcome to the Ramsay show
hello Dave thank you very much for
taking my call boy I sure need your
advice we'll try how can we help okay
well
let's just say in the past I'm 68 years
old
right now in the past
men's anything I ever did was let's just
say it would make you cringe as far as
money goes however at this age in my
life I'm about three years from
retirement I mean I can retire now I'm
working I have social security and small
attention I'm taking all at once the
question I have is this I have a small
mortgage on my house and a car that I'm
leasing those are really the only debts
that I have right now and in my bank
account let's just say 125.
I want to pay off the house and then
start putting that money into like the
401K for these next three years but
people are like every time when they see
money here found here it's like no no I
can invest in this I can invest in that
so I'm not too sure what I should do
should I just wait till I retire and
then pay off my house
why do you want to wait till retirement
to be free
um
admission is and here's the other thing
that maybe I'm just old school don't
know really honestly ignorance
I worry about the income that I am
having coming in right now working
full-time
collecting Social Security and on small
pension all at once putting money in the
bank then I won't have anything to claim
just me
on your taxes
yes on that on anything I mean does that
matter so then I would have to really
make sure so that I am not paying extra
I would have to really
yeah you're not claiming anything now
you're not itemizing you're taking
standard deduction now aren't you
I believe so I think you are you're you
have a small mortgage and a car lease
that's not deductible the mortgage the
interest is what's the balance on your
mortgage
right now it's 73 000. and what's your
interest rate
[Music]
4.2
oh four times seven so 2 800 bucks is
your annual interest
you're not clean you're not claiming
that
that's not enough to be your your
standard deduction is probably 15 or 18
000 bucks you're taking standard
deduction so you get no tax benefit
whatsoever from this house mortgage
and you certainly don't from the and car
and car leases aren't deductible
right that
that I will by paying this off you just
don't give the bank three thousand
dollars a year in interest which would
be kind of nice
oh definitely definitely how much is in
your saving how much is in your account
how much money you got you said you had
a hundred how much 120 right now I have
a hundred and one twenty of your
mortgage in your car today
all right all right how's that wait
breathe that in what's it feel like to
have no payments
oh it sounds good yeah now what are we
gonna do we're rich now
because you got all your income to start
investing
okay that's the thing though with the
investment because everybody I meet
wants to take the money and put it here
put it here put it lock it up for three
years why are you wanting to meet with
people like that
just keep running you know
every time they see my money they want
it yeah just bounce on that you need to
get online and get go to Ramsey
Solutions and find one of our
smartvester Pros so that once you've got
all of this paid off and you're working
full-time you're going to invest 15 or
more because now you got your money
freed up and you can start really
packing away on your retirement and as
you know what are you working two more
years
at least two more years I'm going to be
going to Bible school so then you know
Paris Bible so I just want to be able to
when I do that well I'm going to do it
part time and then eventually my second
year I'll be full-time get a smart
investor Pro in your corner and don't do
what they say learn from them and do
what you say
nobody gets to tell you what to do with
your money not even me
and I'm good at it
but not even me you get to decide you
get to decide Auntie I'm teaching today
and I'm giving you an opinion of what I
would do if I woke up in your shoes I'd
be debt free by the end of the day I pay
off that car call the lease company find
out what it takes to pay it off and be
done with it call the mortgage company
find out what it takes to pay it off and
be done with it and then I would take
the fact that I have no car payment and
no house payment and I would load up a
bunch of mutual funds and build me up
some money so when I go to Bible school
I got a little pad and never lease a car
again ever ever and you don't need to
borrow money ever again that's right
you're now rich people K is with us K is
in St Louis hi Kay how are you
I am certainly blessed that's the reason
for my call ah cool what's up
um well my family believes in
generational wealth
and based on their amazing decisions I
have been blessed to get get incoming
over a million dollars wow
yes
I knew these people existed but I've
never met one way to go that's awesome
who was it Mom and Dad or grandparents
grandma was 94 and she passed away
peacefully and was ready to go to heaven
so it turned out she had been saving and
properties were sold and wow
wow that's I can't even hardly imagine
how can we how can we help you
so the only that of my mortgage that's
automatically going to go away
um
like a hundred thousand dollars good
okay so now we got 900. okay
well it's going to be more than that
that's at least what it is as of now
that there's other things coming in so
in excess of a million so I don't I
don't want to do anything big with it I
can't obviously put it all in one
account it's over 250. good so I guess
my question is is what do I do with this
for a year until I can actually absorb
this and sit down and take the time like
um high yield savings account yeah I'd
pop it on I'd pop it in some high yields
and some different banks
okay so you're not over the 250 are you
married
okay well you can put you can put 500 in
One Bank
right if you got both names on it so
yeah and the um
yeah if you want to do that and just let
it sit there for six months and then
study and read and listen and learn and
think yeah and study and read and listen
and learn and think and get some people
in your corner that have the heart of a
teacher again like we were just telling
the last caller the smartvestor pros
yeah I'm I'm just I'm like you I'm blown
away by this I think it's really
exciting and I I agree with Dave you
don't need to make any quick movements
you've got time to think about this and
I like what he said about listening and
learning because here's the thing at
some point you are going to make a move
with this money and you are going to get
with an investment Pro and you want to
be able to understand what they're
saying you want to have be able to
invert your say on it and say this is
what I'd like to do and have those
conversations and know exactly what's
going on and until you know exactly
what's going on don't do anything
yep yeah just take your time and so I I
end up with Mike my investments K uh in
real estate that I pay cash for and in
mutual funds that I understand and both
of those things you probably got a
learning curve on and then you can
decide if that's right for you but
that's why that's all I do mine's very
very simple and uh and I ended up with a
lot in both of those categories this is
the Ramsay show
[Music]
foreign
12 11 whoever works his land will have
plenty of bread but he who follows
worthless Pursuits lacks sense
Benjamin Franklin said he that Waits
upon a fortune is never sure of dinner
that's good I love it whoever works his
land will have plenty of bread but he
who follows worthless Pursuits lacks
sense you know I'm it's one of the
things that's distressing we had this
labor crisis event the other night with
Mike Rowe and he and I were talking
about work ethic in America today and
the um the Tic Tac people have made
quiet quitting and mediocre Monday and
whatever else this Chase to the bottom
this race to the bottom with no ambition
and no attempt to be excellent at your
work yeah do as little as possible do as
little as possible
um
and let me just help you with that Jesus
did not write that that was Karl Marx
this was from the scriptures he whoever
works his land will have plenty of bread
but he who follows worthless Pursuits
lacks sense
Jackie is with us in Los Angeles hi
Jackie welcome to the Ramsay show
and we deserve what's up
step three
um and I'm a bit just a bit confused so
I know it's time to invest 15 for
retirement that's four and I'm a teacher
and they automatically take away 11 from
our check
um for retirement so I'm kind of
confused on what to is that part of the
15 or is that separate
so technically if you're the money that
they're taking out that's your money
from your check right they're not
matching it in any way they match 16 of
that
so they match 16 of what you're putting
in
the 11 they take
16 of your 11 right okay I see so two
percent whatever they're matching that's
just icing on the cake right so you're
still going to contribute 15 of your
actual personal money and then that two
percent is going to take it up to you
know 17 and that's just fine that's
think of it as a cherry on top do you
get to control what that goes into
I don't okay the fact that you can't
control it I wouldn't I would want to
put more than the total of 15 I wouldn't
I wouldn't count your 11 as the total
I'd count it like I'd maybe count it
like nine and but I'd want to put
another six or seven in something else
where you can control the investment
because if you can't control the
investment you can you can't control the
outcome that's true okay okay and then
just quick question um so I'm trying to
save obviously it's really hard over
here but I'm still trying to save for a
down payment
um what I
still can I put like it's like six
percent still and then still save on the
side or should I pause saving the six
percent yeah pause saving the pause
saving the six percent so in order you
would do baby step three be first which
is saving for your down payment that's
what I would do and then go on to baby
step four where you're able to max out
that contribution
okay okay perfect I appreciate you guys
thank you so much for taking my call
you're welcome thanks for calling in
sometimes people do both at once and
that's okay too I feel like if you're
going this is the way my brain thinks of
it if I'm going in order and I haven't
bought yet I'd probably I'm PR I
probably would not start investing yeah
but sometimes people think it's going to
take a while and they're really upset
about not getting their employer match
yeah or other things and they want to
get started it's okay if you do some
investing or if you even do the whole 15
and you just save up your down payment
in addition to that it's all about how
quickly you want to get your house
exactly exactly so any of those qualify
under what we call baby step 3B but I'm
with you my personal tendency is I'm
just going to be I'm getting her done
yeah yeah
folks who have
this first and it's not that's not
that's necessarily true it's really
about what you're valuing most at that
time yeah and how it's just we're both
valuing the investing it's just the
speed of which you're going to get to
either one exactly exactly and some
people are like I just gotta get a house
put it on pause Greg is in Idaho Falls
Idaho hi Greg how are you
I'm good how are you guys better than we
deserve what's up good great
um so right now we are in baby step two
we have about 25 000 in debt uh 20 000
student loan the other five is like a
family loan
um we're expecting a newborn baby so we
pause that
and and we're just saving for the baby
that's gonna be due here in November
cool so my question is right now we have
yeah thank you
um right now we have a rental a home
it's got a mortgage on it and we're
trying to decide if we should keep it
and still rent it out as an Airbnb or if
we should sell it and use the equity
that we have in it to uh pay off debt uh
do the emergency fund
um and then if it's okay to do home
renovations on our new home like finish
our basements and do a fenced in yard
there's still money after that I was
wondering what your thoughts are on a
mortgage recast
um to do a lump sum payment towards the
new house to get the monthly payment
down a little bit because it seems like
sometimes our monthly mortgage payment
is
like around 27 and I know you suggest no
more than 25 percent of your take-home
pay
I was just hoping to see what you guys
thoughts and all if you sell the rental
how much is it going to bring
um so I talked to a couple Realtors to
get some they were thinking like
a rough number 370 000 and the balance I
owe on it is about 175 000.
how much do you owe on your current
mortgage
uh so our primary mortgage that one we
owe 292
000.
um you know I I'm not opposed to selling
this rental if you're not into you know
renting it anymore if it's causing you
more stress than it is I mean you do you
do have some debt to clean up and you've
got a baby on the way if that's
something that you feel like simplifies
your life and it goes along with your
life plan I feel like that's a great
idea
um I think you want to sell it
um a little bit Yeah because I think a
brand new baby and an Airbnb at the same
time is enough to make me go crazy yeah
it feels crazy those two things at once
and you your wife is saying I need to
get some stuff fixed up around the house
here and you don't have the money to do
that and you're thinking about her and
about the baby instead of the Airbnb and
I think that's a good dad
how close is it to you yeah is it far
I know it's it's like five miles down
the road from us so yeah it's right here
I love the idea of you selling it and
clearing out this dead and possibly
having some left to you said you could
fully fund your emergency fund pay off
the debt and maybe still have some to
put on your house yeah or or you know
dump some in a college fund all those
kinds of things you're not going to have
as much as you think you're going to
have but you're going to have some and
you got rid of the hassle Factor well
you got a brand new baby and life is
good you're clear you can come back and
buy rentals later but if you didn't own
this right now and you had 150 000 in
the bank you wouldn't go buy a rental
today
right yeah probably not yeah so I'm just
reverse engineering on you here yeah so
Jake's exactly right I I agree with her
I would just clean this up and you'll
get you another rental you bought this
at a different time in your life a
different stage in your life your head
was in a different space and right now
you're in dad and a good husband mode
and you're thinking more about making
sure all of the the the the you know the
fort is a secure uh we've got a fence
around it all this kind of stuff and
yeah I like every bit of that I would do
every bit of that be very careful don't
overspend obviously uh we want to make
this money go as far as it'll go but
yeah that's definitely the direction I
would go personally and then you'll get
another rental later you'll save up and
pay cash as you Bill wealth later on
down through your financial piece baby
steps process
now the business of he said recasting
his no I would not reach do not recast
recasting a mortgage is refinancing it
to lower the payment based on a new
lowered balance we don't want to lower
the payment we want to increase the
payment we want to get out of debt not
stay in debt longer recasting means I'm
going to stay in debt longer no recast
no no no no no no no no no yeah no no
yeah because that's just changing the
payment it's not changing the interest
rate it's not much it might change the
interest rate well if they will recast
that at the current rate that's they'll
start they'll charge a fee for doing
that usually but I wouldn't even do that
no thank you yeah nope the goal is to
pay it off that's right not to not pay
it off
and that that's the whole process here
hey good question that puts us hour of
the Ramsey Show in the books we'll be
back with you before you know it in the
meantime remember there's ultimately
only one way to financial peace and
that's to walk daily with the Prince of
Peace Christ Jesus
[Music]
hey what's up guys it's Jade look if you
like what you heard in this episode and
want to know more about getting started
on the Ramsay baby steps go to
ramsesolutions.com and click the get
started button we'll help you figure out
the best next step for you based on your
specific situation that's
ramseysolutions.com and click get
started
[Music]